-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy-nominated,
Emmy-winning writer,
comedian, and actress.
You can see her
next in "Maestro,"
which is
in select theaters now
and streams
on Netflix December 20th.
Let's take a look.
-Have you met the gang?
Betty and Adolph.
They're just a riot.
-Hello.
-Ellen. I'm sure
you've run into her
in mother's studio, no doubt.
-Hello, Felicia.
-Who did I miss?
Have I missed anyone?
-Just the piano player.
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, I figured you needed
no introduction.
-Hello.
I'm Lenny.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Sarah Silverman,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-This is so nice of you
to come out east.
You're from your home in L.A.
right before the holidays.
-Yeah, yeah.
Oh, God, yeah.
I just spent a week with my,
um, common-law in-laws.
-Okay.
So this is Rory.
How long have you
and Rory been dating now
to have a common-law in-law?
-Well, I think it's supposed
to be 10 years,
but we've been together
three years.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
That's enough.
So, common-law in-laws.
Did you luck into it?
Do you have a good pair
of common-law in-laws?
-Oh, they're so great.
I love them so much.
And my, uh -- his dad,
Big Jim, um,
is a real raconteur.
-Okay, tells a story.
-So it's fun, yeah.
Oh, he tells such stories.
They're not --
They're not original stories.
They're not -- you know,
he didn't make them up,
but he just -- like --
Wow.
I sat with him
right before I left,
and he told me the entire...
scene-for-scene story of
the movie "Legends of the Fall."
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
I had never seen it.
-It's good!
-It is good.
-A little long.
-It's a -- It is a long movie.
I would imagine,
without the visuals,
it might be a little longer.
-Yeah, well...
Theater of the mind,
like the Mummy Christmas.
-Yeah, like,
Fred's always talking about
theater of the mind.
-I like theater of the mind.
-Um, this is --
speaking of visual,
this is a beautiful film
that Bradley Cooper directed.
-Isn't it?
-It's gorgeous.
-A feast for the senses.
-It is a feast for the senses.
This is his film, "Maestro,"
about Leonard Bernstein.
You play his sister.
-Uh-huh.
-And you're wonderful in it.
-Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
-Did you love you --
-Did you love...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...period costumes?
-Um. Oh, yeah.
It's really --
It does all the work for you.
You got a costume, and they make
your hair old-timey,
and they put stuff on you,
and you get a cigarette,
and then --
And the dialect coach
tells you how to talk, and then
you just say the words.
-And then it looks great.
It looks great.
-Yeah.
-How well did you know --
Did you know Bradley
before this?
-Yes. You know, it's --
That's such a trick --
I did an interview with,
like, a newspaper, uh, lady.
You know,
"Hey, what's the scoop?"
No.
-Yeah, we all know
how newspaper ladies talk.
[ Laughter ]
-Person.
-Yeah.
-Newspaper person.
-That's what it's called.
-Yeah.
-Um, and, uh...
she's asking me about "Maestro,"
and she said, "Did you --
How well do you know Bradley?"
and I said, uh --
You know,
I didn't want to be like,
"Oh, we're buddies."
You know, I don't --
You know how it's not --
You know, I go,
"Uh, I know him.
I've known him peripherally
for a long time, you know?
And we're not buddies.
But, you know, we've known
each other a bit here and there,
but, you know, not --"
And then I did, like --
We've been doing these
Q&A's after screenings,
and I was backstage
like a week later
with Bradley and Carrie and
and Matt Bomer,
and Bradley goes,
"You know, an interviewer
for the piece on you called me.
She said that you said
we didn't know each other well.
I was like,
'We're totally good friends.'"
And I was like,
"That's so weird.
Yeah, we're totally
good friends."
And I'm just telling --
Now if he sees this,
I'll be like, "I don't know.
I didn't want to be like,
'Yeah, we're good friends.'"
I mean, I don't know.
I don't have his e-mail address.
But I have a cellphone number.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like
that's a better friend.
Like, if we --
Like, for example,
if you only
had someone's e-mail,
I would say that person has told
you, "We're not friends."
-Right.
-But I've only had
his cellphone number
since the movie.
-Okay.
-Making the movie.
But we -- you know,
I've seen him around.
-Was the newspaper person
ever, like,
"Just give me
a straight answer, kid!"
-Eh!
-"Do you know him or not?!"
[ Laughter ]
What do you mean 'peripherally
for a long time'?"
-What is it to know someone?
-Oh, my God.
-"Look, I'm trying --
I'm on deadline."
[ Laughter ]
I want to congratulate you,
as well.
-You have, like, the "press"
thing in your hat.
-Of course.
That's how you know, yeah.
That's the only way you know.
Otherwise, that's when
like,
"Can I see your credentials?"
and they show you their hat.
-Like...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You had a wonderful special,
and it was nominated for both
a Grammy and a Golden Globe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Someone You Love"
is wonderful.
-That's what it's called --
"Someone You love."
-Yes. And this is, uh --
You can see it on Max.
Correct?
-That's right.
-And you filmed it --
You've done --
This is your fourth special.
You've done your first three
in L.A.,
which has been home
for a long time.
But you went back
to the Wilbur Theatre,
wonderful theater in Boston.
-Yes!
-And we're New Englanders.
Did you feel like
it was nice to do --
I mean, did they feel like
a hometown crowd still to you?
-"Hometown hero makes good!"
-Yeah.
"Barely knows Bradley Cooper."
[ Laughter ]
-I love playing the Wilbur.
It's always good there.
And it's Boston, which feels
like the closest to home...
-Yes, of course.
-...without actually going home.
-Right.
It's a good like hour buffer
from where we grew up.
-It's a 40-minute,
45-minute "buffah."
-Yeah. It's a good to have
a little "buffah."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Boston,
you, obviously, have been
nominated for some awards here,
obviously for this.
You won an Emmy
for music and lyrics.
I didn't realize
that your Emmy is for
"I'm [bleep] Matt Damon."
There you are.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, this is
a Boston collaboration.
This is my --
This is my "Good Will Hunting,"
this song.
[ Laughter ]
Was that -- I mean,
that must have been so --
I don't know.
It's a ways back now.
But it must have been
so fun to do.
And the response to it --
I remember this was, like,
the first thing
that everybody was like --
that I knew that everybody's
like, "You've got to watch that
on YouTube."
-Yeah, like, went "viral,"
you know, back in the day.
And I remember, after that,
people would like,
want me to make videos for them.
And they're like, "We'd like you
to make a viral video."
And I was like, "Yeah,
everyone would like to make
a viral video.
That's not your decision.
Like, you have
no control over it."
-I was like, "You know,
it's just a new word
for 'popular,'"
like, when they used "viral."
-"Could you make a smash hit?"
-Yeah.
-"Sure, I'd love to."
-"I would love to.
They just --
They don't always work."
You've had a career
full of smash hits,
but I did not know...
-What are these pictures?
This is one
of your first --
Which "Star Trek" franchise --
-I'm here promoting
"I'm [bleep] Matt Damon"
from 2007...
-Yeah, and then...
-...and, uh,
"Star Trek: Voyager" from 1997.
-But all all of these things
are later than, you know,
when Leonard Bernstein was born.
So these are all more recent.
-Okay, good.
-But "Maestro" --
do see "Maestro," but I also
want to talk about this.
So, "I'm [bleep] Matt Damon" --
Basically,
what you're saying is,
Bernstein, Silverman,
basically the same.
-I'm saying you're
a composer, as well, yeah.
All right. But here you go.
This is "Star Trek: Voyager"?
-Oh, first of all, I kiss him.
I love that you have
this picture.
I don't have my glasses on,
but this does look like
the back of my ass.
-Yeah.
-I kissed him
at the end of the episode,
and he was standing
on an apple box
because God forbid you're
the same height as the girl.
-Yeah.
-And then I made out with him
in real life.
-Oh, wow!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can you tell us what job
you had
on this episode
of "Star Trek: Voyager"?
-I play a scientist.
[ Laughter ]
And I went for the fitting,
and I go --
They've got me in, like,
a half shirt.
-Yeah.
-"Yeah, you're a scientist with,
like, a push-up bra
and a half shirt."
-Yeah. And it looks like
a very tiny backpack.
Like, it feels like a scientist
would have a bigger backpack.
-Right.
And then that's my VW van,
which for a very long time,
I played someone
who drove a VW van.
I think three different things
I had this car.
-Really? You probably
got really good at it.
At that point,
they were like --
Your agent was like,
"She can do it."
-The stick is, like, a long
stick with a ball at the end.
-It's not easy.
Not any any actor can do it,
but Sarah can.
-That's right.
-You're so wonderful
in this movie.
It's really beautiful, and it's
always so great to see you.
You guys,
that's Sarah Silverman.
-I love you.
-"Maestro" is in
select theaters now and streams
on Netflix December 20th.
We'll be right back
with Greta Lee.